all right welcome to a very special
edition of begin to break down am your
host Mike comer we have a fan submission
from Brazil he reads high st. Louis
chess club here's a big fan of the
channel and really enjoy and learn a lot
with the video lessons of all GM's that
support the club especially Yasser Syria
a cobian and my comer not Grand Master
here is a game I played can you go over
it gracias bras Rodrigo all right browse
you're in luck today we will go over
your game alright so in the game let's
see what color up browse has the the
white pieces here okay and he starts out
the Queen pawn d for black counters
Knight f6 the reason he brings out his
Knight to f6 here is to control this e 4
square so if anything goes on e4 black
will take so white Connor c4 black plays
e6 and now he does not want to be
checked so he's like I playing a three
and I don't want to be checked okay but
debt debt check really wouldn't hurt him
but it's not it's not the end of the
world because now this Bishop is going
to look for something else to do and it
doesn't have much to do so black plays
d5 here attacking the sea pawn and white
calmly just develops his night here so
now the bishop can't go and pin it so
now he's restrained to this e 7 square
so then a white brings out his night and
black gets castled so now so now what do
you think White's plans should be in
this position and I'll give you a hint
he just saw black get castled the safety
and he's all chillin in this castle
living it up while all this other guys
have to do all
the work you know that's where that's
where the king wants to be in the castle
right okay so so but you know if you
play III here you know your box in your
bishop so first things first let's get
the bishop something to do all right
ezzo fish up up so he attacks the bishop
so we could just move him back here
right tempting the opponent to destroy
his beautiful castle yes just leave it
out all right all right so that's that's
another lesson you can learn today don't
put hot food in a refrigerator okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so so black should
play G floral he shouldn't have played
g5 but you know he wants to but but
he'll just destroy his castle so you
shouldn't be moving your pawns in front
of your castle so so instead our hero
here white unfortunately just captures
the night am I capturing it he makes
this Bishop that was on e 7 so mighty
you know and he let all the pressure
just out of the position unfortunately
okay so now he still wants to get castle
so he should just play III here
unfortunately he plays efore okay so if
you are not castle and your Kings in the
center and your opponent is castled the
safety right the last thing you would
want to do right is break open the
center of the board right yeah makes
sense to me so he should just take it
here and say he's like you did something
crazy I'm gonna make a crazy move and
I'll have all the pawns in the center
and so so white attacks the bishop all
right I can't blame them and so now
we've heard about this a lot you know
your thread so instead you get insulted
instead of just retreating you're like
I'm going to make a threat just as good
as my opponent did so who could you
attack here that's worth the exact same
as this bishop it's black to move so you
have to attack something of equal value
of this Bishop so bishops are worth
three points you know how much Knights
are worth they're also worth three
points okay so if you can generate an
attack greater or equal to this attack
you'll be doing okay so is there any way
we can attack this night here this night
yeah this is the night we want to attack
all right well if you can find a way to
attack this night I would love to hear
all right here too h4h roque you could
play Bishop to h4 you'd be like just ask
you a please take my bishop and we'll
just trade okay is black is black smooth
so you want peace you will yeah so see
our bishops under attack so so in this
game in this case a good move would just
be to retreat the bishop the safety
right but but he's going to he's going
to make a move that generates an attack
just like the bishop so how in the world
could he attack this night here in one
move this night one move so you make a
move and also know my God my Knights
attack so if we play Queen to a five ok
so this nights and a pin so then he
takes our bishop are we going to take
his night back
yeah we wouldn't want to do that he's
just going to take us back and man we
just lost a bishop a queen for one
measly night that didn't work out very
well that don't work out well at all so
who else can attack the night and i'll
give you a hit it's pretty close to the
night really closest like it's like so
close oh yeah at this pawn right okay
pawn takes one that's what I that's what
are the Nemesis place here he takes and
a he's attacking our night but it's okay
we're first okay so whenever you do that
whenever you you make an attack greater
or equal and you think you're so hot
stuff right well guess what you're going
to be one temple behind this whole time
so let's see if it really works out for
this guy sure no cuz cuz look we're
attacking his bishop and he didn't do
anything about it he decided he's going
to attack our night so we're like we're
going to go ahead with our plan straight
through yes yeah so so yeah so we attack
a black Bishop black decided to make a
threat greater equal to our own so we
took our pawn that thread the night so
when we take his bishop guess what he's
going to do he's going to take our night
but it's okay we're going to take his
paw now and destroy his castle and
thread to get a queen the king you know
he doesn't like doing any work you know
so he's like I'm not taking that pond
you deal with it okay so now the rook
just moves the safety and so now what
what should white play in this position
do you think
the king is not in check but the pawn is
attacking the rook right so the rook
better move I guess he didn't want to
take he could take the pond but you know
he's very lazy and and this and this
this pawn is actually preventing a way
from getting any cool checks in right
now so it's kind of like even though
he's he's knocking on the castle he's in
the castle this point is in the castle
he's really just being like a gentleman
right and kind of not really messing up
any of the furniture nothing cuz cuz
this pawn takes diagonally so so yeah is
not in that is that in the line of the
king so so if white was smart here he
would just take this pawn here but he
wants to keep this g seven-point alive
even though he should realize that that
black has no intention of actually
capturing the pawn so he decides to
protect it with this Queen here so he's
like okay you give me a free point I'll
take it so Queen takes the pawn back or
actually he doesn't take the pawn back
he should instead he moves his rook over
so now we gotta check on the board
there's three things you can do to get
out of a check you could capture the
piece delivering the check if you're
lucky enough you can block the check or
you can move the King to safety you
cannot castle to get out of a check even
though he can't castle anyway in this
position so he decides the black with
the night and so now pawn takes the pawn
so now he plays Bishop takes the pond
and now black finally gets his night out
and now it's attacking the Queen so
Queen takes the pond
alright so far so good and now black
plays check so what is in the same line
as this Queen here a lot of things and
so you got diagonal lanes you got
vertical lines and you got horizontal
lines okay so when the diagonal line
what's in this same line as the Queen
the parsha spawn and this queen and also
this pun but he's irrelevant right now
and then obviously the king so what
should wait to hear he's got a lot of
options what do you think the best
option is did they get that Bishop it up
in there all right so that's an option
you know I don't like they like to
retreat you know fact I hate it it's
like it's not cool all right so so we
could play [ __ ] up the e2 you can play
King to f1 we can play King to d1 where
you play knight to e for double blunder
or we could capture the Queen which one
of those do you think we should do yeah
catch the thick wait wait capture the
Queen right and then the night takes our
bishops under attack but you know it's
like who cares you know with our nights
protecting it and one two three four
five pawns and he's got five points but
this point is probably going to get
captured here huh there's no way I can
never see to save it
so so so basically so so he so they
checked right the queen is in the same
line as the king the Queen is also in
the same land as the enemy Queen here
right so all we have to do is take it
right Queen takes the Queen yeah we move
the king so we take the and then the
night takes and that would be the
position we had just trade two queens
and this position isn't that bad for a
white I mean he's definitely not winning
but but it's better than the alternative
and said he Prince's King in the center
of the board after the check okay and so
now King takes the pawn we attacked the
rook or the rook attacks the Queen so
Queen takes the Queen rook takes and now
can you see a move that makes up why
just give up in this position it's so
powerful Wow yeah you'll be like wow so
so in this position blacklegs rook the
d8 and unfortunately our hero just
doesn't have the energy to go on after
this so I mean in this position you guys
gotta gotta fight on there's nothing
cool about premature resignation okay
it's like you know there's nothing good
that can come from it right you could
still battle on you're only down one
pawn and his Bishop pretty bad yeah bad
Bishop and that's making this rook bad
so you just got to look for the
positives in the position okay sure
you're not castle but you know you could
just move out of the pin here and and
life goes on okay it's
yeah you can just move around just say
hey just try to beat me somehow try to
beat me how you gonna do it oh yeah you
got to figure out something okay all
right so so thank you for the online
submission willow will try to try to
respond two more of these as they come
in here all right next game up is uh
let's try to find another good game here
all right it's my game and i'll show you
when you should resign all right yeah
all right so i had the black pieces
against the dr. Shulman & and my whole
mindset was to obliterate I'm okay so
let's see if if it comes to that okay so
white plays efore so I try to confuse my
opponent and play something I've never
played before Knight f6 so what is at
act of whites right off the bat which
one of his pawns or pieces is under
attack right now efore right so he
should probably defend it but instead of
you decided to play night of three and
up he's now down upon for nothing so
Queen attacks the night so protect night
attacks the pawn and the night so you
know you got to give them double puns if
you want double pawn so bad there you go
buddy all right enjoy them living the
life so Bishop now pins the night so
Queen gets out of the pin and also
attacks the pond so bring the night out
Bishop e2 so so now the Knights really
not in a pin all right so II five so all
right so I think I'm really good I
played e5 I got my whole plans all
working out and he well he attacks my
bed
so I decided to go ahead with my own
plan of forking the night and the Queen
but what move does he play so my pawn
actually cannot capture either of them
even if they wanted to so bad you got
ideas coming Queenie three puts the pawn
in the pen and so now I'm mad so when
you're mad you take something okay
luckily I didn't take the pond I wise up
and took the night all right and so now
he's like oh haha you can't take my
bishop so I'm like well we'll see about
that so I play Bishop to e7 to get out
of the pen and now he's looks foolish
because he got to move his bishop right
back all right all right but but yeah he
doesn't have double pawn so so we must
be feeling pretty good because he saw
these and he's like oh man wait why did
I want these though it's all right so i
get castle the safety this is great all
right and so he plays d3 so so you know
so there's some moves I could do here
but if I took even though it be breaking
open the center it would be undub lling
his pawns I'm not doing him any favors
okay because I'm all about obliteration
hey so f5 and I saw a four key move
don't get don't cancel the safety play a
four right good job so when you play f5
it just looked like hey I just played up
five to protect the pawn which is true
but I also played it so I can play f4
and keep this thing rolling so back up
alright so now Bishop to h4 threatening
the big check so if he plays his
grandiose plan of moving to a pawn all
right what's super move do I have here
any ideas and we saw that how I fort the
night and the Queen earlier to no avail
but I did it but I saw that and I it's
fresh in my mind so it's like yeah I
want to fork everybody with my pawns so
I have a touch no I would I would
actually take this pawn with check yeah
yeah yeah King takes yeah the bishop the
bishop right yeah yeah sure oh wait yeah
so I got the pond and now do you see the
king and the Queen and so who can who
can give them a check here to win the
Queen yeah yeah one of the puns this guy
because they capture diagonally so they
had the big check and it would be
devastation for a boy but I guess he saw
it because he's like I'm going to take
that pawn so all my plans are ruined now
so I take but I'm still going for it so
he plays g3 he should just captured my
queen here right ok but ok so g3 so it's
like all right i'll take you to pawn
takes Bishop takes check now he's got no
no castle here he's got nothing nothing
going on so so the computers like hey
just get your queen out of here and then
and there will be threatening to play
like Brooke etudier and all the good
stuff but you know what I'm just gonna I
just I see a check
and so he takes back and now oh I play
III here alright so I don't I force him
that make the Queen trade with III and
then Queen takes check Queen takes no
check Queen takes no check rook takes
check and now he's got a better move
than Bishop 2d to this Bishop blocks the
check here alright so this pawn this
Bishop rather is it a pin everybody
knows what do we do to pin pieces we
attack them or pile on okay just pile it
on alright so Bishop attacks my rook now
it's a force moves looking really good
and so now I bring my rook up right in
his face all right so King c1 he's
trying to to make his own like little
makeshift castle over here yeah good
luck yeah so I could take rook takes
bishop and the night takes check but I
figure hey why don't I just have a
superstore Brook and so now he plays c4
so what do you think I should do here
anybody got some ideas what I should be
thinking about the brook
give them another check just for the
heck of it well if might get my pulling
all the way to the back row I can get a
queen if I want which I probably don't
but but I could i get i get ya so
pulling up threads rook check you want
to get a queen you forget that pawn
going alright so now they play the king
up to attack our rook here okay so we
could get a queen with uh with check and
then you'll take our rook or we could
make a move with check that actually
saves our rook what could it bid you see
a Kevin under promote with a double
check and now the night checks it
protects the rook and the King has to
has to flee so so now we got four pieces
to his three and we're going to go for
checkmate so there's only one good check
on this board right so what would it be
because remember we don't want to put
the rook too close to the king because
Kings can capture pieces if they're not
defended so should I check with this
rook or this rook that one yes excellent
and now he's only a one potential move
the c1 so now now do you see what this
night is protecting you see how this
night is protecting c2 in this position
and Kings cannot capture protected
pieces so we can swing this rook get
this that this thing the rook rating is
face here because he can't capture it
because the Knights protecting it so now
he swings this guy over and now we have
checkmate in one move
see how this night is protected by the
bishop this rook is protected so if we
can give him a check that's a good check
not one that just gives a ruck away for
free we're going to be the champions I
assume you're talking about this one
right and that's checkmate and the game
is over yep Kings got nowhere out okay
so cool all right so Jonathan saw me
beating up on this guy so much he's like
I got to get in the in the picture here
all right so we're going to we're going
to let them get in the picture here all
right so this is the first one Jonathan
had white against dr. shoeman all right
so f or e 5 Queen to h5 we've seen this
a lot in a beginner breakdown so what
are the chances dr. Schuman is going to
have a defense for this so queen is
attacking the e pawn here so really
defend it here's the moment of truth
drumroll please he doesn't he doesn't so
Queen takes pawn check Bishop e7 night
up counsel but he got cancelled so he's
feeling good he's feeling good but now
Jonathan knows exactly where this King
is so he's going to get all his pieces
over there probably and try to do
something all right so rook to e8 see
how the rook is now in the same Lane as
the Queen here so he's threatening to
play funny moves like Bishop to a three
so he just get him off the line just
keep it simple right that way there's no
tactics you can fall for all right so
he's like I'm going to attack you anyway
and now his pawn is not looking good
making his bishop even worse alright so
Queen Queen up all right so he's got
dreams of checkmating on each seven now
alright so now he's got to find a
different way out for his Bishop all
right so now [ __ ] up attacks up seven
excellent okay and we all know the
Knights probably gonna be hopping in
here any second now if he lets them all
right so so Jonathan didn't fall for the
the first time the bishop was in the
same Lane as the Queen so let's see if
he's going to do it this time alright
castle so now he's feeling good zo
anywhere he moves this night the bishop
is attacking the Queen so he's going to
have to play a door d phi first all
right just to throw them off guard pawn
takes and now Knight takes d5 and you're
like what the night is under attack by
the bishop and the night but you see how
it would be very silly for us to capture
it because it would be bye-bye Queen it
was a discovered attack so I bet you
Jonathan's going to see it and he does
but look at where he goes this must be
dr. Shulman's birthday he's like you
went right into the the bishop Brooke
combo here so he must be feeling pretty
good however he's got to deal with this
night so let's see if he plays c6 here
nope he decided to play Knight f6 it
attacks the Queen but leaves the rook
hanging oh but now now he's going to
concoct away to a trap as Queen I bet no
sorry sorry audience he did so he
decides he's going to attack the night
d3 try to get this Bishop Bishop play in
here all right c 6 here it is here comes
the trap he's not afraid night attacks
the bishop but more importantly what
else did this night attack f7 the
crucial f7 square so we better play
Bishop to h5
Oh instead Bishop to e6 asking him hey
destroy my pawn structure okay and it's
like okay if you want to I'll do it and
now we can just Knight takes c6 okay
interesting night takes so is he going
to take the Queen or is he gonna take
the free night free night every night
good job and now he's threatening check
let's see if he sees it alright he
blocks it alright Bishop to d6 and now
he's got an attack coming here all right
yup there you played this it does work
funny stuff like Bishop H to check
doesn't work cause you're going to get
background check mated King takes Knight
check and then if King g3 Queen takes
bishop checkmate alright so so funny
moves like that unfortunately do not
work for black in this position but
they're worth looking for and I said
he's like put the Queen and the bishop
but he's got them backwards right it's
like you rather have the Queen in front
he might just let it happen it's like
whatever I don't care I does let it
happen oh well okay so-so bishop took
the night he could have just played
Bishop check king pawn takes and then of
course it was going to trap it with g3
but still kind of fun to play yeah well
well unfortunately we don't get that
third one because um Bishop check king
pawn g3 Bishop takes pawn takes we can't
take this or else at least it's not
checkmate this time hopefully
let's try let's keep let's keep this
dubious variation yeah so so so okay so
so he just took our night okay so
instead of just taking it right back
we're like we're going for the check
then the King move so the only spot now
we take the bishop so after g3 Bishop
takes pawn takes and now we're like okay
we really want to take this pawn but we
know the Queen will take our work if we
do so we're just going to get a tempo
here and watch what this temple does it
leads to probably made in five here
Queen takes check King g7 oh wow yeah
wow and it's it's uh you can't even bear
to watch it anymore right right yeah so
so he decided dr. shoeman wisely decides
okay it's a poison pond so he just takes
back and so now night to e4 can he
resist it one more time no no way no way
and now we can just play Bishop to e5
here oh it does and he's probably
feeling pretty good he stopped that so f
4 so now he's like oh my god I get
another pawn so now rook so now he's
going to find a safe spot for his Bishop
but oh no besides and well it's going to
be all over pretty soon here check check
all right we'll take the bishop first
obviously check night up I know who
would resign in this position or a hero
from game one you'd be like oh yeah it's
over now Brooke Queen up so you see the
rooks in a pen so he's just attacking
the pin piece it can't get any simpler
than that
no so he offers the trade here well
everybody's laughing so maybe they can
live it like it they can let me in on
the joke here what move would you play
here I know what I would play I probably
just retreat the Queen probably there
because it threatens check all right all
right mystery so it's always like oh so
you can just be funny and play there you
didn't play there that's funny alright
so first things first check king here
alright well what would he go ok so
right o Queen here or work age 50 check
them again came back
that of six cool yeah yeah me you're up
so much material you could just take if
you move the night no mate Queen see 80
see that the night is blocking eights
the pivotal 87 square and then check me
so that was good that was good so
Jonathan was like you know that took a
long time to beat him that time this is
like ridiculous I'm a I'm a busy man
okay so so he's got he decides no more
this mr. nice guy it's all about AB
liberation all right so let's see if he
can do it a little faster here all right
dr. shoeman starts out efore and now
Knight f6 he saw my game and how good I
was when I played the alkynes but dr.
Shulman knows hey I should probably
protect this pawn so he plays Knight to
c3 so now II 59 of 396 of four nights
games because all the nights are out
really original alright Bishop c4 Bishop
c5 d3 so now so you just max them okay
d6 the mirror image i would have castled
whenever you can cast will just get
castle late i put it off h6o in case the
double ponds now if you were dr. shoeman
would you be like I actually castle the
safety here dr. Schulman so we do Castle
kingside in this position if you were
white heck no cuz then black and play
rook the GA and just crush you all right
so he's like I guess he knows his
flippers night to the side of the board
alright so an idea for white should be a
queen queen here and the castle long
well alright night up and now he's like
okay it's all safe now that my night is
over in this corner here that I got g2
covered and life is good all right so
let's get them first things first we're
not going to let the Queen down here all
right fair enough all right so so I
wonder if he's going to put this night
in a pin how did I know how did I know
all right so Bishop so now you got to
play the dubious f3 here are you better
not play f3 if you play up three what
would be so wrong with moving this f
three Pawn here anywhere this night goes
it's check the discovered check pretty
powerful so he's got up bring his his
night up here so check pawn takes Bishop
takes and we still have the pin and
we're threatening something cool so all
right so he's got to get this Queen out
of the pin here so if he gets the Queen
out of the pin and after rook check
we're not checkmated and we don't have
to lose our queen right what move can he
play the night and then of course app in
peace what do we do to pin pieces
everybody should be yelling it attack
home right attack the pin pieces right
but unfortunately dr. shoeman ye just
plays a h4 trying to create a little
flight square for his King let's see how
it goes let's see i goes i see i mate in
a2 that's a good i am
yeah you do all the hard work I'll find
the maiden tubes I stopped looking once
I find me oh you just want to give them
your rook you just want to say oh you're
probably still winning that's the funny
but you probably don't want to give them
your pieces okay but but that was a good
good ideas you know you look for the
checks you know so you find the one
checking your like old man takes my rook
so get that get that one out of the yeah
just clean up oh give them no option
yeah and you just just like you playing
all the way to make and just hope I just
hope hey stranger things have happened
he might he might want to double his
pawns up and then check mate all right
game over all right that's obliteration
for you all right so cool thank you for
the submissions and stay tuned for next
week will be the season finale of a
beginner breakdown I might even tell you
what the meaning of life is all right so
be sure to stay tuned for that